who doesn't like manny pacquiao I was at
that photo booth he beat him up and I
remember watching you know Freddy was
going you know what fray was saying put
him out you know what man he said I
don't want to hurt him
I know well I watched this great
interview with Dan Patrick and Manny
Pacquiao oh I'm sorry I'm Freddie Roach
dan Patrick in Freddie Roach and they
asked him they go what changed in what
what was the biggest change in Manny
Pacquiao and he goes when he got knocked
out by Marquez that he was just
different
yeah the killer instinct was just
completely go to sleep yeah well yeah
one of the worst nights of all time but
he goes because he never really suffered
a loss like that and to get a knockout
you take some risk II made a huge
mistake right stepping inside his left
foot and so you got hit with this
straight right he goes he's never like
helped that had to deal with that he was
once that happened yeah when he came
back from training ditch the killer
instinct was gone because like oh well I
don't want do that again I don't want to
hurt people because I got hurt and he
I'm just gonna went off skill now I
don't wanna hurt anybody
it's very strange man I haven't been
remotely in the same [ __ ] that was
the cause he's not in a back out but
when you do get knocked I like oh no I
don't want to do that anymore
like done try but it's not it's not
gunshot you don't fight reckless in him
right like that's what happens GSP you
don't wanna do it happened to you having
at GSP GSP got knocked out and never
fought the same again he just because
you go oh that's the consequence if you
don't know the ignorance is bliss and
once it happened to go
oh dude [ __ ] that Emma makes a little
for me like for my little bit from what
I know of fighting yet so you go but
it's true I got the first time I got
knocked out like I got kicked in the
[ __ ] head knocked out I just heard a
loud pop went down and from for a year
after I was I was you know what I would
do and I would never create distance I
run in and just stops like trying to
stop something cuz I couldn't be on the
end of those punch it made me gunshot
and actually I was never I was never I
was like oh this is what like fighting
is with guys and every time I go to the
[ __ ] studio I'd be nervous
getting knocked out is the worst it's
the worst and if it's your job
holy [ __ ] practices like you know you
the way you guys far as stupid then back
in the day Shan I'm surprised you didn't
get I'm surprised you didn't get gun-shy
after spying with Shane Carwin Soph I
never got knocked out yeah yeah was the
first time you got knocked out right
right right yep huh but then I just
chalked up as a fluke cuz hit me behind
the ear so I cast that real well I'll
deal with that and then and Nogueira
Nogueira was the one with a gaffe [ __ ]
and then I came a little good not even
really gun-shy cuz the cars just being
stupid I thought Rothwell then two
knockouts back back then might then I
was like nope you were beating his
[ __ ] ass - yeah then I was like nope
no more of that I don't feel that
anymore so that way I went straight to
grass and wrestling yes yes like now
I'll just double like you how's like why
would I do this
it's been CEO Ben Askren returns
I'm sure depends on would imagine that
again you can you can whether one right
it's it's well it's just you bents I
mean that's such it it's I hate when
people call it lucky but it's just you
know it is the perfect storm where you
got knocked out he's undefeated grappler
and then that [ __ ] happens so you can
just be that that's never gonna happen
to pan again as long as he lives that's
never gonna happen again
Janson banking knocked up by flying me
in the opening bell it's not good yeah
so he's gonna be fine
look at that Maas balls a huge start out
as well he should be crazy why because
he beat Darren till cowboy Cerrone
stopped all of them and now I like it
when guys gonna fight that long and they
finally get their do yeah at Harrison
Justine I'm just taking a long [ __ ]
time to squirrel that horn rose wow
that's a long time that's pretty painful
to it painful and that guys not losing
this hair god he does not give a [ __ ] my
favorite is the beginning of that fight
where he looks at him in smiles and puts
his hands behind his back yeah they
hated each other I think he was right he
goes oh so it's you can say anything you
want after this before the fight and
then when I knock you out a little
showboating that that's not people
upset really okay look at that no it's
great right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]